can we talk about some
candidates the ones we got and possible
alternatives
so one question i have is why
do we have within this system why do we
have the candidates we have
is it seems um
maybe you can correct me highly
unsatisfactory
like the like is anyone actually excited
about our
current candidates i'm kind of excited
because no matter who wins the election
it's gonna be hilarious
so that is something that i'm excited
about from uh from a human perspective
yeah
is that is that what the whole system is
uh so that's the one theory of the case
is the entire
thing is optimized for viewership yeah
and
excitement by definitions of like the
reality show kind of excitement
i think it is if you look at what
happened with brett kavanaugh
this is not a career that would
draw people who are you might say
quality
because no matter who they are there
would be a huge incentive from the other
team
to denigrate them and humiliate them in
the worst possible ways because
as the two teams lose their legitimacy
among gen pop
it's going to get harder and harder for
them to maintain any kind of claims to
authority which is something i like but
which does kind of play out in
you know certain nefarious ways so
people the best of the best are not
going to want to be politicians
yeah because like i could have a job or
a job interview and i'm running
yahoo or whatever or i could for 18
months
have to eat you know corn dogs looking
like i'm going down on someone and shake
hands and
have all this my family and on social
media daily
called the worst things for what and
then i'm still not guaranteed the
position
but the flip side of that like from my
perspective
is the competition is weak meaning
like you need a certain a minimum
amount of eloquence clearly that i don't
uh
the bar which i did not pass i don't
think either of them would be considered
particularly eloquent
biden or trump no i know but that's what
i'm saying the competition
like if if you were um wanted to be
become a politician if you wanted to run
for president the opportunity is there
like if you were at all competent like
if you had so like andrew yang is an
example of somebody who has a bunch of
ideas is somewhat
uh eloquent like young
energetic it feels like there should be
thousands of andrew yang's
like that would enter the domain and he
went nowhere
well he ju well i wouldn't say he went
nowhere he generated quite a bit of
excitement he just didn't go very
far that's okay you don't have to run
for president to generate excitement
with your ideas you could be a podcast
host i'm not even joking
that's right that's right that's right
and he's both andrew hang oh he's a
podcast yeah he has a podcast called
yang
speaks oh okay cool
[Laughter]
oh wow the music of the way you said uh
yeah cool is the way my mom talks to me
when i tell her something exciting going
on in my life
oh that's nice honey oh you made a robot
that's cool
that makes coffee oh you're still single
though aren't you
i wonder why i wonder why make yourself
a robot wife
give me some robot grandchildren um
okay but
first of all okay let me ask you about
andrew yanks he represents
fresh energy you don't find him fresh or
energetic
you know like is there any candidate you
wish
was um in the mix that was in the mix
you wish was
one of the last two remaining yeah
people like marion williamson i thought
was great
uh tulsi i thought was great amy
klobuchar got a bad rap
i think she held her own smart she
wasn't particularly
funny that's okay i think she was
non-threatening to a lot of people what
did you
like about them i guess i just named all
women that's interesting it wasn't even
intentional um tulsi i like that she was
aggressive
has a good resume and is not um
staying the course for the establishment
marion williamson i like because she
comes from a place
from what it seems of genuine compassion
maybe she's a sociopath i don't know
i read her book and it actually affected
me profoundly
because it's very rare when you read a
book and there's even that one idea that
blows your mind
and that you kind of think about all the
time and there was one of that such idea
in her book
about um she was teaching something
called the course in miracles in
hollywood i think she still teaches it
and this was during the 80s the high the
aids crisis
and all these young men in the prime of
their life were dropping like flies
and she's trying to give them hope well
good luck they're dying no one cares
and they're like you can't tell us that
they're gonna cure this
like you're that's a lie and she goes
what if i told you
they're not gonna cure it what if i told
you it's gonna be to like diabetes
they cut off your foot and you're gonna
go blind would that be something that
you can
hope for and when you put it like that
it's like yeah like if you're talking to
him like a homeless junkie
and you're like you could be a doctor
you're a lawyer or a lawyer like cool
story like
you could have a studio apartment with a
terrible roommate and a shitty job
but when you're on the street you know
cooking need
breakfast in a teaspoon and you hear
that you're like wait
would that really be so bad is that
really so much worse than this no
and it becomes something so when she put
it in those terms i'm like wow this
woman
that really did a number on me in terms
of teaching people how to be helpful
small steps but it's but it's also then
it becomes less of
i need a miracle to be like oh this is
really magical
yeah it's and it's absurd to think it's
impossible
what about what's your take on ud 2020
that
brett weinstein uh
pushed forward it i i it was d.o.a
uh he couldn't even stand up to twitter
dead on arrival then rival he couldn't
even stand up to twitter let alone or to
facebook they got blocked let alone
wasn't that hugely problematic by the
way that twitter would block
that not at all um i don't know why they
blocked it but i believe
i don't know problematic means that's a
word that does a lot of work
uh that people wanted to do conceptually
um the
idea that like unity is like taking the
rejects from each party
and we're gonna like have something that
no one likes and therefore it's gonna be
a compromise is
absurd the last time we had this kind of
unity ticket was the civil war
when you had andrew johnson from the
democrats and lincoln from the
republicans this was not something that
ended well
uh particularly nicely for both halves
of the country so that that's the way
you see it as
like the way i saw i guess i haven't
looked carefully at it i haven't either
to be fair yeah
the way i saw it is emphasizing
centrists which is uh
how's celsius centrist tulsi was
involved yes
he's trying to push tulsi and like jesse
ventura or something oh
so oh okay i don't know i don't know the
specific as a scientist you also know
centrism is not a coherent term in
politics
but see now you're like uh uh what is it
pleading to authority
no i'm treating my ego no no i'm
pleading to how you approach
data if someone is saying the mean is
accurate
that only me i mean the mean could be
anywhere it's a function of what's
around it doesn't mean it's true
i don't even know what uh census is
supposed to mean but what it means
to me there's no idea essentia
centrist there's more of a center right
or center left
to me what that means is somebody who is
um
a liberal or conservative but is um
open-minded and uh
empathetic to the other side joe biden
had the crime bill
joe biden voted for republican supreme
court justices joe biden voted for a
balanced budget joe biden voted for
bush's war he and i'm sure probably
haven't looked this up the patriot act
joe if you want a centrist you have joe
biden yeah okay he's worked
very well with the republicans that
argument could be made of course they'll
everybody will always uh resist that
argument
it's undeniable in fact during the
campaign some uh
um uh activists started yelling at him
at a town hall not yelling just saying
hey
we need open borders joe biden says i'm
not for open borders
go vote for trump and literally turn his
back on the man and this is during the
primaries where it would behoove you
to try to appeal to the base and of
course you can probably also make the
argument that
donald trump is center right if not
center left well i mean
he's he's very uh unique as a
personality
but if you look at his record and his
first name is rhetoric you can say is
not centrist at all
but in terms of how he governs the
budgeting
i mean has been very moderate it
certainly hasn't been like draconian
budget cuts
uh the supreme court you could say okay
he's hard right immigration you could
say in certain capacities he's hard
right
but in terms of pro-life what has he
done there in terms of
you know so it's in many other aspects
he's been
very much this kind of me too republican
but certainly the rhetoric it's very
hard to make in the case that he's a
centrist
so you don't like uh is there any other
idea you find compelling like you
what i like about unity 2020 is just an
idea
for a different way for like a different
party a different
path forward so ideas just like anarchy
is an interesting idea
that's that leads to discourse at least
i don't think it's interesting at all
and here's why i think it's interesting
uh sweden has eight parties in its
parliament
iceland population's like 150 000
they've got nine i think it was czech
republic has nine britain has five
um so the claim that two uh parties is
the sensorious of speech but three oh
now all of a sudden it makes no sense
doesn't import to the data number one
number two is donald trump demonstrated
that you can be basically a third party
candidate seize the machinery
of a existing party and appropriate to
your own ends as bernie sanders
bernie sanders has never been a democrat
uh major credit to him for
that's not easy to be elected as center
as an independent he's done it
repeatedly
so these are two examples of ossified
elites
uh right for the picking so to have a
third party makes
no real sense
you